Trump faces 76 and a half years in
prison yeah in Georgia 91 counts
717 and a half years overall man these
they think he's like a Biblical guy he
lives like to 700 years plus death
penalty uh uh uh so former president
Donald Trump could face up to 76 if he's
convicted and receives a maximum of all
sentences then 13 counts he faces the
indictment uh filed by Fulton County
Georgia district attorney Fanny Wills
late Monday night here at accounts one
violation of Georgia's Rico racketeering
influencer by the way this was for the
mob up to 20 years five facility
solicitations a violation of Oath by a
public officer up to three years nine
conspiracy to commit to impersonating a
public officer 11 conspiracy to commit
forgery in the first degree 13
conspiracy to commit false statement and
writings conspiracy to commit filings
false statements that's another five
years conspiracy to commit forgery in
the first degree seven and a half years
conspiracy conspiracy commit false
statement in writings two and a half
years filing false documents 10 years
solicitation of violation of Oath by
public officer false statements of
writing solicitation a violation of Oath
by public officer another one false
statements in writing again hundreds so
in addition he faced 136 years and 34
counts in New York case
450 years and 40 counts in the Miami
case oh my God 55 years and four counts
in the federal case in DC and Trump
could face up to 717 years in prison the
latter charge in DC also includes the
possibility of death penalty first of
all it's comical at this point but you
know what Trump should have listened to
Chuck Schumer remember Chuck Schumer
warned him the Department of Justice has
seven ways of Sunday to get you and
let's just all be clear Trump didn't try
to overturn an election Pat he was just
suspicious that the left was trying to
cheat again okay they were cheating in
2020 with the whole FBI like stopping
the hunter Biden story and all that
stuff with Joe Biden Hillary Clinton
cheated in 2016 when she tried to
undermine the election with the whole
Russian collusion and you know what
pisses me off about out of this the
worst Pat is that the Republicans I'm
sick and tired of people like Kevin
McCarthy uh Jim Jordan Matt Gates all
they're doing is barking if you watch
all these Judiciary hearings from
anything from the indictments to covet
to everything they are the biggest
sitting there barking and saying they're
gonna do this and how many whistles have
to be blown how many whistleblowers how
many smoking guns need to be found Pat
till they actually do something nothing
nothing is going on and that's why it
keeps bringing back to the point that
they're all on the same team Republican
Democrat same same freaking team one
just barks doesn't bite and the other
one is is getting away with murder and I
just want I hope that The Independents
out there are watching if you don't see
what's going on with Trump right now
you're either a sheep or you're like
you're just too dumb to understand
what's going on I I keep saying to my
theory Tom but you go first I'll give
mine after yours so when I look at this
remember we we broke down um who was it
Ellen Bragg in New York and how he had
inflated everything remember that Pat
we've done a podcast Alvin Brooke Alvin
Bragg
and the D.A New York and here's what's
happening here take away everything that
says solicitation and conspiracy
conspiracy says two guys were thinking
about it talking it over so let's don't
say they did it and solicitation there's
a time and a place for that that's
called Congress the only thing you see
here is that first count violation of
Georgia RICO Act so you actually did
something everything else here is just
stuffing the turkey with bread there's
nothing really here except that one big
count and they are attempting to make
everything seem better by adding up all
these years this would never happen if
you and me were indicted like this in
Georgia the 76 years would go down to a
year and a half for Rico if we were
convicted this is just this is fluff
they are fluffing and puffing up just
like Bragg did in New York city so when
people hear about this you just have to
realize just how political size this is
and what is really a count here and what
is really oh and also conspiracy
conspiracy conspiracy conspiracy
conspiracy seven of those two three
solicitations this is that's ridiculous
conspiracy and solicitation even if you
prove it people go okay so Tom and Pat
talked about doing something in the
insurance industry did they do it no but
it was conspiracy to commit but they
didn't actually do it all right well why
don't we give them both a 200 fine and
get them out of here that's what happens
in these things this is how long do you
think they've known they're going to be
doing this for a while oh this is time
this is on a calendar in somebody's
office hey on Thursday that's when we
need to do it but Tom honestly like you
you're sharp guy how long give me a
timeline have they known they're going
to be doing this for two years for a
year and a half for for one year for six
months how long have they known they're
going to be doing this I would say
probably a year and a half because six
months after Biden's inauguration they
knew he was politically having trouble
I'm guessing probably on the January 7th
yeah
even before then because you had to
figure out that they were gonna go there
and protest I'd say a couple of days
before because then you had to have FBI
agents inside the capital outside
pushing people to make you become this
thing to have it come down okay so let
me ask you so these people that I've
been working on this for as long as you
say that yes yes who who are they loyal
to are they loyal to hear me out are
they loyal to
uh Biden are they loyal to Obamas are
they loyal to the party who who are they
loyal to for the country it's definitely
not the country destroying the country
we look we're looking big that's the
first time in the history of America
that this has ever happened with any
president then there's been a lot of
stuff that's happened in the past before
this is not something that we practice
to look this pathetic in front of the
world so who are they loyal to who's
their loyalty
I'm not saying this is the case but I
would hope that their loyalty especially
if they're prosecutors and judges and
doj that their loyalty would be to the
law okay what do you think their loyalty
is to Tom I I think they're loyal to the
Democratic party okay I agree it's two
district attorneys that have been put
out there and I don't think these DA's
know that they're being played history
is going to have their name do you think
they're not anybody do you think they're
more loyal to the Constitution to the
law or their political party the
constant what exactly the party so which
case are you talking about because
they're all wildly different no of which
case any case that they want to put this
guy away there's well if you're talking
Alvin Bragg in New York or if you're
talking the Mar-A-Lago thing yeah I'm
with you but the Georgia thing I think
is totally different you have a governor
Brian Kemp you have the lieutenant
governor what was his name it's like
katzenberg or something like that these
are Republicans these were people that
voted for Trump you also have Mike Pence
who was the boot licking VP who is the
probably star witness in the January in
the January 16th so I'm just I'm just
saying that there's a nuanced
conversation here I don't think Brian
Kemp is law
okay so let's stay there Brian Kemp was
even asked if Trump is the nominee will
you still vote for him he said yes so
you're right he did say if Trump's the
nominee I'm still going to be voting for
him Mike Pence is a different story if
Mike Pence is truly about the
constitution in America you know what
would happen if Mike Mike Pence was
really that
his followership and popularity would go
to the roof but it hasn't it hasn't from
anybody no okay so so then here's
becomes the motive becomes
we want to get rid of this guy because
he's going to come in and drain the
swamp and guess what let's eliminate him
okay this is even the Georgia thing it
isn't anything that clintons and others
haven't done in the past before okay but
the only thing is it was on tape that's
the whole thing so no doubt I mean I'm
sure the buttons was on tape saying if
the prosecutor doesn't do this and it's
the guy that his kid was getting money
from the back and he's still our
president United States and no one so so
to compare Biden stuff to Trump it's not
even a comparison well there are even
Nixon the Watergate tables yeah I mean
that's how they get you here's where I'm
going with it the point I'm trying to
make is the following point if they've
known for a while Tom that they're going
to be doing this okay if they've known
for a while Adam I want you to think and
play The Devil's Advocate here sure let
you so what percentage do you think
that the people who are on the inside
that know these things are coming and
it's time because it's time perfectly I
was telling it to Russell Brand
yesterday when I was on the show I said
uh you know the whole thing how every
time Biden got in trouble the exact next
day Trump gets indicted three four times
it's the same exact day you have to be a
dummy naive oblivious or like you're
happy they're doing that to say no
there's no chance this is accidental I
run no it's happened many times
okay the timing is weird the timing is
weird so do you think the guys that know
they're writing this up to destroy Trump
do you think by any chance they've
spoken to DeSantis and knew some about
it
I would say they've spoken to Newsome at
DeSantis knows
I would you would say they've spoken to
Newsom but the scientist knows what I'm
saying is I think I think there's been
like straight up conversations but I
think they would have probably worked to
flow it to the santis go deeper like
what kind of conversations you're saying
oh I think it's it's very subtle
Converse I think it's it's this kind of
a conversation let me kind of unpack it
for you make a role play so so so so you
got you got these guys that are doing it
yeah the people on the left know so
person on the left that say you know
maybe a leader or you know exactly I'll
read this here in a minute with Natalie
Ford those keep and scored three 1700
bite in the midst laptop 318 trumpet
died mid news six eight FBI doc alleges
Biden bribe six nine indictment seven
twenty six hundred please deal collapse
of 727 in debt and 731 Devin Archer
testified eight one there's four times
back and then new one go to the bottom
one on what she's got okay eight nine
one Biden bank records release 811 doj
did their special account so we can go
on and on and on and on uh with these
types of things that's happening but
here's where I'm going so they know hey
guys we're about to drop the bomb and
we're gonna destroy this guy he will
never have a career in politics he'll be
done and he'll spend the rest of his
life in jail I'm talking about Trump
here yeah yeah I'm talking I'm talking
about we're about to do this to Trump
great got it so a couple of the guys say
hey you know what I want you to do what
uh I'll give you bone okay go whisper to
your guy run
that don't worry about Trump he's not
going to be there at the end
it's his position
go whisper this to him
you think so yeah just go whisper to him
or indirectly well listen don't ever
tell the scientists I don't want him to
know it's a sign of what go tell him
because you know in that dirty World
whatever you say don't tell they go tell
these are dirty people right some of
them that are in the dark sides of
politics
so then a guy comes up and says hey you
mean all of them so I'm not saying all
of them I'm not saying all of them I
actually do believe there are some good
Statesmen out there it's very hard to be
a good Statesman you have to realize in
every space there's dirty people and
there are states when I'm convinced
there's plenty of Statesmen there too
but it's very hard to stay a true
statement over time so then one guy
comes hey uh listen
um you talk to one of the sentences
right hand guys so look it's between us
I want to whisper this too but please
don't say anybody that I said this to
you here's what they're going to be
doing to Trump so it's going to be an
open
you know run for him he's pretty much
going to be the candidate he has to lose
it to not be the nominee oh really yes
then they come back and they say hey
here's the news guess what take our time
we're launching the campaign we don't
have to be as aggressive going out there
wait
then defend him and say the fact that
the OJ is going after him then defend
him that this is not the right way to do
because you'll seem like a hero and
you're going to gain the mega crowd
what are the chances that that kind of a
conversation has had where the news has
been given to him to say this is your
opening because he's not going to be
there at the end
uh
what are the chances that a conversation
possible I would say all these types of
shady conversations are happening no
doubt I what I will say so I'll agree
with you what I will see if those
conversations did take place you know
follow the money follow the numbers it's
not helping uh the sentence campaign no
but his numbers are Plumbing but don't
you think that's not that's not on
that's not on them though that's on him
yeah but that's not on that's not
because you have to have the talent to
get the eyeballs and if you can't sell
the dream of why you ought to be the
candidate and you're just talking
logical stuff and it's just policy
policy policy policy policy you can you
can't get the people then I'll go deeper
if there is that conversation happening
which I think maybe we'll see I think
they're Whispering it to everybody here
at Pence don't drop out of the race this
is what may happen but hey Governor
Christie stay in this thing hey Tim
Scott you could be the first black
Republican boom hey Nikki Haley I don't
think they're just gonna put all their
chips on to Santa if that's
conversations are happening but they're
brilliant wait and I'm I'm going even
further back those guys are not a threat
though no not at all that's what I'm
saying so Pat why would the Democratic
party want to do all this to Trump and
say Hey Ron you're gonna you're gonna be
that guy because they know they could
easily be wrong because he hasn't done
Biden Trump is the threat Trump is
the threat and if you don't see the
cheating if we were all racing on Monday
Pat and on Sunday I know that you're my
only challenge it's me I know and I know
that you're faster than me you're
issuing if I knew cops and like maybe a
judge I'm like hey go go arrest Pat I'm
gonna go set him up and that's cheating
they're cheating they're taking the legs
out of the number one guy because they
want Ron do they want if it's Biden
you're saying that Ron DeSantis uh that
Biden could easily beat Ron I think
easily he'll be doing all right that's
fully disagree with you don't think Joe
Biden's good what if Rhonda Santos was
the candidate I think he would whip up
on Joe back I don't think so I don't I
think that's why I don't get his vibrant
he's not exactly the most the best
marketer but you're going against Joe
Biden who's not a marketer at all I
fully disagree I think DeSantis would
whoop up on Biden then why they why are
they propping why are they getting rid
of trump because DeSantis is the next
guy they're just getting rid of trump
because they want to get rid of trump
regardless of who's next but as a plan
you would have to know that the number
two guys gonna you know I mean they're
gonna have to go against that's a better
fight for them is this anthis is that
what you're saying like that's a that's
a look if you're looking at the general
election matchups what you just talked
about 10 minutes ago Biden and Trump are
still at a dead heat I have a and Biden
DeSantis are within two points I want to
believe what you're saying Adam I want
to believe what you're saying but I'm
not convinced uh DeSantis is going to
beat vivec I'm not convinced DeSantis is
going to be able to take Levesque out I
think vivec is
um is is and by the way we're going to
learn a lot about the debate the first
debate that's coming up on stage we
don't know if Trump's going to be there
or not when is it most likely uh uh uh
it's coming up like in a week or so 23rd
we don't even know if uh Trump's going
to be on stage or not but if Vivek comes
out and he puts on a show and all of a
sudden you see the Santas drops off and
Vivek goes up you're gonna be like wait
what just happened here that's pretty
wild that's number one and I say one
thing about vivec I'll say that guy is
an absolute Beast he's an absolute stud
but you're gonna say what his religion
Hindu that is running as a republican
Christian Evangelical you're telling me
they're going to vote for a brown Hindu
guy
we'll see about that okay all right if
he was running as a Democrat that guy
would be the next Obama no doubt vivac
good Plumbing good point by the way by
the way let's see okay let's see you
have to still be able to sell the dream
I think he's in the scientist doesn't
know hasn't shown yet how to sell the
dream he sounds like a guy that's
talking to you that there's an element
of I'm smarter than you and I'm better
than you and trust me just you know I
know and that doesn't relate a little
Hillary Clinton asked yes a little bit
it's just upon you trust it's the one
you trust more it's a it's a guy that I
actually think he's got solid characters
and values I think he's a good guy I
think he's a good husband good father
but he's also been wanting to be a
president since the womb he's been
wanting to be president for a long time
I put those two I don't think Trump's
been wanting to be a president since day
one I think RFK just wanted to be his
father's son and spend time with his dad
and his heartbroken devastated 14 years
of being addicted to drugs from 28 to 42
he's lived a hard life the guys lived a
very weird life not saying he doesn't
have the additional stuff where I'm
going with this is the following
you know if if you truly are thinking
the centers would do better than Biden
if you truly think the centers would do
better against Biden
why why are you eliminating Trump as a
candidate
if if Democrats are more Street
strategic than the right why not wait
to go after Trump if he's not even a
candidate he's gonna he's gonna be gone
why do you care about him so much
if you think well I think the center is
going to be to Biden no problem all this
stuff well then you know no problem
if you really think that's it then let
Trump be the candidate because you know
you're going to be Trump
these are very the Democrats you I
respect them so how United that group is
the level of unity that the Dems have
over Republican Republicans compete
against each other Democrats are like
nah man I can't stand you I hate you
you're the worst human being in the
world but what are your Democrat we're
on the same page bro we're going to be
all right that's how United they are on
their party I'll give you a little
feedback on the Democratic party uh
they're just whoever's leading in the
polls they'll try to dismantle it's
Trump it's the scientist they'll go on
and so forth I think if you're a
Democrat right now you are about to run
literally the worst polling president
you've possibly ever run ever okay so
Biden
75 of Democrats are like bro don't do it
bro don't do it but he's doing it and
they're all gonna coalesce and get in
line but nobody's excited about Biden
and uh well I think it's going to be a
so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]